Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Squarespace launching their new campaign.
Make your next move, make your next move and set new goals for this year.
Lock down your next move idea with a unique domain and create a website to
launch today by using offer code Radiolab for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website.
Make your next move with Squarespace more@squarespace.com this is Radiolab Jab,
Homerun, and I'm Robert Krulwich.
In this hour we've been talking about the placebo effect. Yes.
About the power of belief and suggestion and thus far we've looked at it from
the perspective of the patient,
but certainly the doctor has a role to play in all of this.
So I have a story to tell you. Five, four, three,
two one zero it's, it happens to be a better doctor. Yeah.
I'm Dr. Albert Mason.
I was trained in medicine in guy's hospital back in the 1950s Albert Mason was
delivering babies at a hospital in London.
He was a young guy at anesthesiologists and he was looking for a new way to
anesthetize his patients, the moms. Some of them may be safer than drugs.
And one day he ran across a book about medical hypnosis,
medical hypnosis,
and I just read the technique and tried it out on some friends.
And under what circumstances, like you,
you would put a watch and have it swing back and forth left and right. No, no,
no. Just lay them down on a couch and say,
I'm now I want you to let your whole body go loose at your arms,
go loose that your legs go loose.
And it worked on some people and not on others. But the more he practiced,
the better he got. You know, putting his friends on to a trans stay,
getting them to remember stuff from their fifth birthday and all sorts of games
that we played as medical students.
And so we took this little party trick into the delivery room and it worked.
That's right. I delivered about 20 babies under hypnosis.
And the moment you start to do hypnosis,
you start to get a reputation as being somebody who has power. Well,
I would think you get two reputations. The patients might think you have power.
The doctors might think you're a quack. Well, both of those are true,
but at that time it was kind of fun because the hospital administrators were
kind of curious about this young doctor. Slash. Hypnotist.
Maybe he was onto something, who knows?
So they started to send him all kinds of patients, skin disorders,
asthma, and he'd hypnotize them,
which led to a weird little discovery of all things that hypnosis might help.
The one that seemed to work the best was warts, warts,
Bortz. To my delight,
I found that if you hypnotize them and told them that the warts would go,
they went in a certain number of cases. Let's fast forward a little bit,
and Dr. Mason is treating lots of these worths patients and things going pretty
well. And one day a young boy came to this hospital.
He was wheeled in on a Gurney and the first thing I saw was his arm.
I could have dropped through the floor because this wasn't a dozen wars,
this was millions. This was the entire surface of the skin.
It cracked and got infected and his life was impossible.
He couldn't go to school because he smelt. Now,
I don't know if you've ever seen the photographs of this boy.
Just check this out. Look at these pictures here. Oh my God.
It looks like he has a, a black hide over his whole body.
It looked like an elephant skin. That's what it looked like. Wow.
So they take this poor boy to surgery. The surgeon, a man called Jerry Moore,
was trying to graft healthiest skin onto the hands.
And when I saw this skin, I said to him, Mr. Moore,
why don't you treat him by hypnosis? And he looked at me and he said, well,
why didn't you? And he walked out with you.
Why don't you in, in despair or in contempt?
I think a mixture of both. And by the way, when you asked that question,
you're the kid asking the senior practitioners. So I was cheeky.
Yeah, you were cheeky.
So there's Albert Mason cheeky alone with his boy with a million warts.
And Albert asks him, do you mind if I hit my ties?
And this kid who was 15 said, okay, didn't you have to tell the parents?
Um, no, couldn't have got away with it today, could I?
[inaudible]
so I hypnotized this kid.
I told him the watch on your right arm will shrivel up and die and new skin will
grow. And why did you choose the right arm? Oh,
I had to start somewhere and I sent him away.
He came back in a week and one of them was clear.
Um,
totally clear. I mean, imagine this,
the left arm is black and scaly like elephant skin and the right arm is totally
normal. Totally normal looking. Here's the [inaudible]. This is a real photo.
This is a, this is verifiable. It looked like a normal skin,
but rather pinker the neutral, slightly pink and soft and supple.
This is for real. Yes.
It's like all those thousands and thousands of words that covered the right arm.
I guess they just fell over. And what were you thinking when you first saw it?
I was thinking how wonderful.
I was thinking, Oh wait, let Mr Moe sees this.
So he takes the boy,
he runs down the hall to the Operating Room when Mr. Moore is in the middle of
an operation. He takes the boy up to the big, you know, the glass window.
And I held up both his arms, one blackened, scaly,
the other pink and raw and more put down his scalpel.
He came out of the theater and he looked and he said, my God,
look at that. And I said, well, I told you a could go.
And he looked at me pitying. He said, this isn't warts,
this is congenital [inaudible] Olam, arithe redundancy of Bro.
Whenever those of us who are uninitiated,
what is Roman [inaudible] gamma guy with Axios, hopeless condition,
never been known to, to change the surgeon,
informed Albert Mason that he had just hypnotized away a condition that never
once in medical history had been known to go away for any reason, whatever.
So he says,
we're going to take him to the Royal Society of medicine to show him to all the
dermatologists in London.
[inaudible]
so more took me up there with the boy.
Thank you Dr [inaudible] and to the Royal Society for this opportunity.
And I demonstrated, first of all,
I demonstrated how to hypnotize is quite easily achieved.
You simply let the patient down and say,
now I want you to let your whole body go loose. Let your arms go loose,
let your legs go loose. And then I showed his arm, please, sir,
if you don't mind, raise both arms.
Cool.
They were staggered. In fact,
the president is upset that it's inconceivable that this gets well because we
all know that congenital [inaudible] incurable
[inaudible],
that was the exact word he used in curable, incurable
[inaudible]
curable. And the thing was, since all this took place at a hospital,
every stage of it was documented.
There are photographs every step along the way before shots after shots,
closeups, all available to reporters. You can imagine what happened, right?
It was picked up in every newspaper, Time magazine, big media story. In fact,
the first I heard about it, I was in bed one morning,
a year after I'd sent the paper in from habilitation and the phone rang and the
voice said, this is whipsnade zoo.
We have an elephant with a skin like a little boy. Can you kill him? And I said,
what's up? I don't know. What the hell are you talking about?
And then the phone started to ring and ring and ring and hundreds of calls,
hundreds of letters came in from all over the world.
And I had people coming in with the most terrifying illnesses wanting to be
killed, especially people with that very rare skin condition,
congenital [inaudible], whatever it's called,
they flocked to him from all over the world.
And that's now here's where the story takes a turn. He would see these patients,
he would hypnotize each one one at a time and then send them away,
hoping of course that they'd get better and they would come back a week later.
And
none of the others ever got well
at all. No,
not in any way. No improvement. Um,
I've spent the rest of my life trying to understand this phenomenon I gave up.
And it's usually a few years later,
Albert Mason quit medicine and he decided to become a psychiatrist.
He wanted to understand why he had the touch the first time and why after that
it just didn't work. So the central question in your mind was,
why not what happened to the kid? But what happened to me. That's right.
That's right. And what do you think the answer to that is like? Well,
there is a condition called infantile omnipotence that we all suffer from when
we're kids.
We think we can do anything unconsciously.
I knew this was incurable. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Are you saying because it's incurable would mean that it had never been cured,
but you've tried. You had tried. Created an exception. So look,
when you're 25 and the president of the Royal Society of medicine tells you it's
incurable, it has an effect. That's his best guess.
He thinks that that word incurable changed him just a little bit.
I lost my crazy confidence even though I had the evidence,
but it didn't work.
No.
Confidence is a hard thing to measure. You can't put it on a scale.
You can't weigh it,
but you can sense it because it's conveyed in a million little ways how you
stand, whether you look your patient in the eye, when you pause,
where you pause, what you say, what you don't say.
All these things are like signals may say to the patient,
they murmur to the patient, I can help you, they can do this. You know,
you go to a doctor, you've got this horrible rash, all of you. And he says,
oh that's everything in my multiform me and you feel better immediately cause
he's named it will.
All he said is many red spots in Latin.
But the thing is that he knows what it is and you feel that,
oh he knows now I'll be okay.
Okay.
Cause when you're feeling terrible,
what you just want to do is hand over the authority for your situation to
someone else who's got information hour
and he's going to tell you you're going to be fine. Yeah.
And maybe that comes from early childhood when it seems to us that our parents
have that capacity. Harvard historian and Harrington,
I have a two year old and a, we're already now at the stage where, you know,
he gets a little bump and he comes to me and holds the bit of his body out.
That's been hurt and I kiss it and it's okay.
And I,
there is a way that mommy's kiss is kind of a placebo effect. Testing,
testing, and now imagine that you're sick. You know when you're sick,
there's a strong impulse to kind of revert back to that way of interacting with
people. You have to say something just to Shuba Duck.
That's Arabic for what do you want? How's that? How are you?
I'm good dad. How are you? I'm doing very well. This is my dad.
Do you see how your voice goes on the thing?
He's the guy I bring my booboos to as a kid. Tell me what you do. Actually,
I still do like your title and that kind of thing because he happens to be a
doctor. I'm the chairman of the Department of surgery at Vanderbilt.
Vanderbilt is in Nashville, Tennessee where we grew up for much of our life.
Where are you? Grew up for much of your life. Okay,
so my dad had no idea why I wanted to follow him around the hospital.
I didn't exactly lead with the whole placebo thing.
How often do you see patients? Truth is,
I feel okay about that because this show isn't really about lying.
It's about healing the healing process, which doesn't happen in a vacuum.
Patient of course, has to believe in the cure,
but the doctor has to create that book. Okay, wait, you have to walk slower.
I can't talk slowly now. How does he do that? Tell me where we're going.
Now we're going into the clinic and it'd be more specific with what happens at
the clinic. I have patients scheduled to come to see me today. These days.
My Dad's hair is, this white is his white Dr Kobish,
but he's still sees patients every Wednesday daily.
I have four patients and that is why I'm here.
1:00 PM clinic begins in the clinic and as if to illustrate an Harrington's
basic point, when you're sick,
there's a strong impulse to kind of revert back to that way of interacting with
people. As soon as my dad's first patient shows up. Hey,
hairstylist from Murphy, I'm a single parent and I own my own business and I,
I've always been in survival mode and I've always had to be strong.
And so that's why this has been so hard for me. They give me two,
a tiny exam room, which is quiet and super intimate compared to the hallway.
Dad Has Megan sit on a table if that.
Okay.
And he gently presses two fingers there. Next Waldo
a little bit. Let's just say
there's a tiny gland in her neck.
That should be the size of a piece nod you put over the past four years,
it's gotten bigger. Three inches and bigger.
Wide and two and a half inches in the other direction.
No, it's the size of a golf ball. She presses against your ear. Yeah. At night.
Sometimes I wake up and you know, it's good and I think, Oh God,
should I call nine one one? And I keep asking him every week,
are you sure I'm not going to choke? It's not gonna choke.
Kit's not gonna choke me. It is not good choice. Sure. You know,
just him reassuring me it's not going to affect the airway.
I try to remember those things that he says to me when I,
especially in the middle of the night when I start feeling anxious or panicky
and I same time,
how do I deal with it and anxiety that surrounding this thing because like I've
got anxious and lots of anxiety, but I don't know.
We're going to scared of the unknown part or that is warn about the future.
I think just because it's just me. Well, I know,
but I guess it's just because of my risk.
My personal responsibilities work with you.
Got To put them at ease is not nothing life threatening
today. You have to put them at ease.
I'm going to give you a short term plan and a long,
okay. Yes. Medicine.
We're just science and all of this talk would be just noise because the real
business within happen in the next room where there's this big machine ready to
scan Megan's thyroid, but medicine isn't purely science. Yeah. I mean,
which my dad had miss. That's an art. It's communication,
which is why he and Megan talk and talk and talk and talk for over an hour.
In a way, it's a kind of negotiation.
She wants to know one thing like what if my thyroid has gotten bigger?
What if I have to have radiation? Will I have to quit my job?
He needs her to focus on anything but the what ifs to stay focused on what they
do know,
which unfortunately is that they won't know anything for another day.
Did he draw the blood today and he goes or not? I know it was in 24 hours. Okay.
I need to know the size of that type of thing.
Okay. Somehow in the end, despite all the open questions,
because as they do that, he gets there to relax. We're going to work together.
We're going to let you guys talk going into town so much.
It's really inconvenient for me. How much performance isn't it?
What do you mean performance? Yeah.
How much of doctoring is having to play a certain role that the patient needs at
that moment? It's just about every bit of it.
So if I were to call it theater, would that offend you or no?
It's not a theater a it is.
I'm living that draw. It's part of me.
It's not part of a fake image that I'm projecting.
I think you know what I'm trying to get at. Really? No,
you call it theater. You can call it theater. But I just mean that.
I mean when you, when you don't have the white coat on you,
you're not like in doctor mode. You know, you don't have all the answers.
You don't, and I don't have all the answers then like, but you,
but you seem to, and you know with her, that's what I really wanted to know.
That magic pixie dust called certainty.
How do you project that instantly to patient? The moment you walk into a room,
even when the patient hits you with questions like Doc, am I gonna make it?
It can seem kind of mystical, that aura. But then again,
there are the props. Okay, you have to tell me what you're doing now.
What does this for instance, to rewind a moment.
Here we are before clinic in my dad's office and he's just opened up his little
coat closet,
my coat on, and I usually on the day of the clinic I choose a clean white coat.
Really? Yeah. Do you have many to choose from?
I have one, two, three, four, five, five,
five blindingly white, white coats.
He flips through them because the white as to the bunch of puts it on and I
swear to you, even now when I'm older,
it's supposedly wise to these kinds of things. It's like he changes somehow.
Do you ever go to see patients without your weight
cut on? Uh, I don't like doing it. Yeah.
It's almost like you're naked without it. You do seem Tyler with it on,
can I do? Yeah. There is inherent power in the props,
especially the code. And if you have any doubt the doctors don't know this,
go to a med school,
any med school on the day the new students arrive and you'll probably find
something like, excuse me, if we could all have a seed,
we'll start the ceremony. The white coat ceremony. Thank you.
It's as close to religious ritual as you can get in medicine. In fact,
the one that we attended at Columbia University in New York,
I asked the students to please stand with me included a chaplain.
Hmm.
As you are able let us pray together.
Compassionate. God
bless these new medical students of the Columbia University College of
Physicians and surgeons and bless the white coats that they receive today.
May these white coats be for each student,
a cloak of compassion, a clear statement of purpose,
a sign of assurance and a symbol of respect.
The ceremony we pray for the Strait and for the Times has some almost spiritual
component. The Art of healing. It's quite moving I think.
I hope you'll find that's Arnold and Sandra gold.
They began the white coat ceremony at Columbia almost 20 years ago.
I'd be with each student and they were in the audience today. We were there,
God be with each of us along with about 250 students and their families first.
Each student is cloaked individually and call by name,
Eric, j. R e s James J. Truck.
They then return to this eats.
So we see this visual transformation that occurs.
This is a change that you can actually see it.
These people come into this room with their coats on their arm and they're
wearing blue and black and green and yellow and that's who they are.
And you see the room filling up in white and they see the room filling up in
white, Alexandra J. Borst. And you know in the old days doctors wore black.
It's true. A hundred years ago doctors were gothic black coats.
But then someone discovered germs and had the insight that germs live in dirt.
And because you couldn't see dirt on black coats had to be white.
They changed for antiseptic reasons.
That is when a certain symbolism to cold. When you think about angels,
they're never in red, they're never in black.
Please turn around to face the audience
and I present to you the class of 2000 okay.
[inaudible] lab. We'll continue on.